Somewhere around seventy five thousand years
ago - don't worry, I'm not going to go too
long on this - but around seventy five thousand
years ago, human beings who were anatomically
and behaviorally the same as us modern human
beings -- a few of them decided to trek on
out of Africa and begin a forty thousand year
project or so of populating virtually the
entire world becoming a global species which
we are now, perhaps the only global species,
with I think the possible exception of cockroaches.
I'm not positive of that but I think that's
correct. And now we find ourselves on the
threshold of becoming possibly a universal
species or at least entertaining ideas of
inhabiting places beyond this earth that we
live on.
So this new migration however, I have to say
is different not only quantitatively from
the original ‘out of Africa’ diaspora
but qualitatively because we're now talking
about a migration to a place that has never
influenced our evolution in any way. And so
the question is, will we be able like the
first migration to be able to do this by the
use of technology and science without really
changing our biology? Or will we now have
to resort to changing our biology to making
ourselves in some way or another more adapted
or more adaptable to environments that are
even difficult to predict?
So let me welcome our panel. To begin with,
our first participant is a geneticist and
associate professor at Weill Cornell Medical
Center. Please welcome Christopher Mason.
Also with us this evening, Professor of Genetics
at Harvard Medical School and the Director
of the Consortium for Space Genetics. Please
welcome Ting Wu.
Good evening, Ting.
Hello.
Our final guest this evening is the Director
of Astrobiology at Columbia University where
he studies among other things the conditions
on other planets that make them habitable
for life.
Please welcome my friend and colleague Caleb
Scharf.
Hello, have a seat.
Thank you.
Good. I'm going to jump right into this with
a question to Caleb, who said in his Scientific
American blog that the possibility of humans
living on other planets is quote, "Terrifyingly
hard to think about and that's the best thing
about it."
What's hard and what's so good about it?
Well I think some of these other people on
stage are going to explain what's hard about
it and what happens when you go to environments
that are radically different than the one
we've evolved out of. But what's good about
conditions on another world or in space being
so horrifically difficult, from my perspective
and what I was getting at when I wrote that
article was the idea that every time humans
are challenged with something radically new
and especially in exploration, especially
in survival, it's the opportunity for good
things to happen. It's the opportunity for
us as a species to expand not just physically
across new territories in our solar system
but as a species our conception of what it
means to be human alters, and our conception
of the preciousness of the origins that we
have here on earth I think expands and improves.
So that was really what I was getting at,
this idea of -- you know there are lots of
motivations for our species to spread itself
into the cosmos. I mean there are motivations
that are quite simple to do with potentially
having a backup plan. Living on a planet is
an inherently treacherous thing, especially
on longer time scales and most of us experience
in our lifetimes. So having a sort of off-world
storage system and off-world backup plan is
not a bad idea.
And of course the scientific enterprise exploring
the universe around us humans are pretty good
at that. I mean we build wonderful robots
to explore the universe around us and that
gets us a long, long way. But there are many
reasons to believe that putting a human in
an alien environment is the single most efficient
way of learning about new places. And I think
the Apollo astronauts were an example of this.
When you put a geologist on the moon, they
did more than a couple of hours than you could
do with a rover in years and years and years.
Chris you think a lot about the future and
long term futures, which I which I find very
intriguing because I think a lot of our science
tends to be, you think of scientific experiments
that you hope you'll see the results of in
your lifetime. So that puts sort of a narrow
vision and one of the wonderful things about
science for me is this kind of wider, bigger
frontier. So you're making plans out for five
hundred years is it? Is that what you're thinking
of?
We're on year five of about a five hundred-year
lab plan.
Is there funding for that?
Not funding for all of it. I will of course
be dead for the vast majority of it. But I
think it's actually really one of my favorite
things. Well first it's terrifying for people
who want to come in the lab they think they're
going to be there for five hundred years.
I know graduate students just like that.
So you know not in the sense to have the experiment
necessarily go that long, but actually to
think about a multi-stage plan to learn as
much as we can about the human genome and
other sort of the ecosystem that we all are
represented by as well as ways to find, sort
of, what I like to call "do not disturb" lists
in places that we can alter to some degree
in the human genome and the other genomes
we have. Because I think we will have to have
this list as sort of, a parts list of the
human genome as some people call, or the areas
that you can tweak because we will probably
need to do it for some of the places that
we'll go. Mars is not a hospitable place.
And so a lot of the plan is to learn as much
as we can in a functional capacity in the
near twenty-thirty years and then begin some
of the engineering and long-term tests of
people on other planets and I think it's a
very quintessential human trait, is that we
all have an innate capacity to actually plan
beyond our own lifetime, which as far as we
know is unique to our species. And so I think
it's our it's your duty as a human being to
at least have one plan that's beyond your
lifetime and the simplest example is just
children. When people have children it's obviously
beyond their lifetimes.
Students.
So one of the places that I think actually
makes a job of planning that is the is the
Consortium for Space Genetics which you direct,
Ting. Could you tell us what you do at the
Consortium for Space Genetics?
Yes. And perhaps the best way to do that is
a little bit of history of how we came together.
Yes please.
So most of us started in the Department of
Genetics without a focus on space. But of
course many of us were inspired by space when
we were young. So what happened is that one
day I went to a conference and I met Adam
Steltzner, who is the person who put Curiosity
on Mars. And we had a chance to talk a little
bit and he agreed to come and talk in our
Department of Genetics because we knew that
eventually the effort to go into space was
going to intersect with genetic information
and genetic technologies. So my department
actually was shocked that he would come and
talk with us. And people were saying, "Why
is he coming to talk to us?" And then it dawned
on everyone, because we are actually moving
together to try and figure out a way to protect
astronauts in space and to think about five
hundred or five thousand years into the future.
And what happened is, that turned into one
of the most exciting and successful symposiums
we had in our department with graduate students
and post-docs leading that. And the faculty
then, following the graduate students and
post-docs, started thinking more creatively
about the work that they were doing in their
labs and how that work might apply to space.
And that is how the Consortium got together,
sort of an excitement brought by a realization.
Can you give us an example or two of how this
alters your thinking about genetics?
It became -- what genetics is moving very
much into, the realm of application and invention
of technologies that didn't exist, and in
fact possibly genomes that did not exist.
So much of the department focuses on disease,
the detection of disease and therefore information
of personal genetics can help astronauts determine
what their predispositions might be if they're
going to go on a long, long trip in space.
We also do a lot of work on understanding
DNA damage and how to repair DNA damage. There's
work on longevity, how to extend lifespan.
And also, I work particularly on protection
against radiation. So those are all the things
that are happening, and the goal in mind is
to protect astronauts on space but also take
what we learn in space to take care of humans
on Earth.
What about zero gravity? What about low gravity,
microgravity? I mean we know it has physiological
effects, we could talk about those -- we will
talk about those when we get to the twins
a little bit later I guess. But is there any
effect of gravity directly on the genome,
on gene regulation, on gene expression, on
any of those sorts of things? Either of you.
I'd say you know very much so. So as soon
as you get into space we see thousands of
genes changing their expression. What we've
seen in analyzing the data from the last couple
of years of this study is that some of these
genes immediately revert back to their normal
state when you return back to Earth. But there
are still hundreds that stay perturbed that
have lost whatever was regulating them, you
know essentially back to the normal state
so we can see this is the short list of the
risk genes, or the space genes that we're
going to keep an eye on for the next -- well,
for every astronaut that goes up probably.
Are these genes that we know what their role
is, their function is? Or are these just -- I
mean this is just looking at, here are the
genes on earth, here are the genes there-
And the ones that change. A lot of them are
stress response genes, DNA damage repair genes,
so there is definitely a physiological and
genetic response to space travel and that
there is a stress response to a larger degree.
But one of the more surprising things we saw
so far is that the telomeres actually got
longer in space and so we often think of our
genome…
Oh! That's good, isn't it?
being fairly, the fountain of youth in space.
You go up to space and technically you're
going closer to the speed of light so you're
a little bit younger than everyone on Earth
and a little bit taller, so you can be younger,
taller, lose weight, and be younger, technically.
I'm going to sign up again. This is going
to be a tough night.
But there's increased radiation, your body
puffs up, there's no shower, and you generally
exchanged all your microbes with everyone
in a small aluminum can basically. So those
are the cons, I guess I'd say.
I see. I'm glad there's no food here.
There are some interesting genetic responses
that we -- we knew we'd see gene expression
changes because those change every time you
eat, every time you sleep there's a circadian
rhythm or even epigenetic changes for how
DNA is packaged. We expected that.
So I was going to ask you actually about circadian
rhythms in space. I mean, it's kind of an
earthbound idea, isn't it?
Yeah. Well every ninety minutes, essentially
you have a new sunrise and there's really
interesting things that we can also see in
the data is when they go to sleep there there's
no up there's no down so they're just kind
of go in a closet and close the door just
so that it's dark to get some semblance of
circadian rhythm. But the other interesting
thing is when you sleep, normally there's
enough currents in the air because we're all
terrestrial beings that you get enough oxygen
flowing by you and the air moves. But in space,
actually you'll end up sleeping in a cloud
of carbon dioxide, so actually we can see
even there when they wake up in the morning,
essentially they've been you know sleeping
in their own basically gas exchange excrement
and then you can see it in the physiological
responses that they're slightly suffocating
during the night. So there's actually a race
to see who can get the best fan action in
the space station to avoid that.
It's that hard to put fans in the space station?
Well they're loud. Some of it's the noise.
But you get used to it after a while.
Caleb you're a physicist, is there a solution,
like maybe we should make more gravity? Are
there ways of producing at least minimal gravity
environments?
Sure. Well you know in a space station spacecraft
you can always do things like spin it up.
So this is something that -- I mean if anyone's
ever seen "2001", you remember famous scenes
where he's jogging around this great ring
that encircles the spacecraft, and the ring
is spinning. That centripetal force can be
used to mimic the acceleration that you feel
here on the earth or some fraction of it,
and I guess I'm not sure it's ever been actually
deployed in space. It gets kind of tricky
though, because unless you build a really
enormous spinning spacecraft hundreds of meters
across, you can certainly spin something smaller
but you have things like the Coriolis effect
to worry about. So if you reach across to
grab something, where your hand is is now
in a different moving frame where the rest
of you is. Or you throw something to your
colleague across the room, it'll kind of go
'wooooo' around a corner. So it introduces
other complexities to living in space. But
my understanding is -- and I don't know if
this is really true because it's not a perfect
mimicry of gravity -- that you can certainly
create a form of artificial gravity by spinning
up the environment and living on the inside
of a spinning ring. And that may help mitigate
some of these physiological changes.
So the space station -- and that's sort of
one thing where there's really virtually zero
gravity. But if you were to be on Mars, you're
not in zero gravity anymore, there's less
gravity than here, but there's gravity. Does
it make a difference -- I mean are we that
finely tuned to a gravitational pull that
that even a small difference makes a difference?
I think -- I don't know if we know, actually.
I mean you know the moon is 1/6 the gravity.
People that were there were only there for
not that long… But the body is quite adaptive,
you can see -- I mean the way we solve it
now on the space station is just with bungee
cords and there's a guy who I met at the human
research program meeting, and you meet people
and he says, "Well I'm the guy who designed
the treadmill in the space station." I was
like, oh that's great, it's really cool to
meet the guy who did that. You know obviously
it's a really cool device but with a limited
market in terms of sales. But it was an amazing
device. And it's a bunch of bungee cords,
a treadmill that's really rigorously designed,
but that is the closest they can get to simulating
gravity. And in the metabolomic data, what's
actually present in the bloodstream, you can
see both the markers for bone density loss
actually the physical loss and calcium shows
up in the urine, as well as all the enzymes
activating for bone deposition, which are
essentially really activated every time you
have something like gravity and so it's an
ongoing battle on the space station for the
astronauts today just to maintain what they
have. But it's hard and I think if you're
on Mars, I think the first generation of people
there would adapt to some degree, I think
the big interesting question would be what
happens in F1, the other second, third, fourth
generations. And that, you know there's been
a lot of science fiction written about how
the people would be taller and misshapen and
look like me in the morning kind of thing,
is what they look like.
So I guess we could get into that a little
bit. I was going to save that for later but
since we're here we might talk about that.
So that would be sort of an epigenetic effect,
right? That by a second or third generation,
you'd begin to see alterations in at least
gene expression if not mutations in genes
themselves as a result of some of these environmental
effects. Is that kind of the idea that we're
talking about there?
So right, we're actually moving into the realm
of Lamarck, where a lineage will pick up a
trait-
I knew he'd come back eventually.
Actually I think Lamarck is coming back, because
this is a proposal that an individual organism,
because of environmental stresses or experiences,
will experience some stress and then its progeny
will actually inherit the response let's say,
that the parent had. And that was looked down
upon for a very long time. However, I can
tell you I was at a meeting recently and finally
someone yelled up from the audience and said,
"Just say the L-word!" And the speaker said,
"OK, I'm talking about Lamarck." And there
is evidence now from many areas to say that
an individual organism may be able to pick
up a response or a trait that will appear
in the progeny in an altered form or slightly
modified form.
And then it will be heritable-
It will be passed on. Right. In some cases
it's heritable for three to four or five generations,
and then the absence of the stimulus will
disappear. In other cases I guess people think
that it can be more permanent.
Even in worms, you know we've seen that multiple
generations -- if you have viruses that will
infect some of the worm C. Elegans -- there's
a model organism, a small nematode. For about
two to three generations they still maintain
some of the defensive microRNAs but then they'll
slowly fade away, so even -- we think of DNA
being heritable, you know epigenetic changes
being heritable but there's even some evidence
that a memory of the RNA responds to a viral
infection is heritable. There's a paper from
Oded Rechavi three years ago that showed this.
And so it's interesting because there definitely
is a cellular memory that is present, what
often we just call "imprinting" but it seems
to be more complex and more pervasive than
originally thought.
I have a question. Am I allowed just a random
question since these two guys are sitting
here?
Sure, why not.
So
Thinking about, let's say going to Mars, people
going to Mars and living on Mars. One of the
things that interests me -- I know nothing
about it but it seems like an important factor
-- apart from the internal microbiome is the
environmental microbiome. Let's assume that
Mars is abiotic at the moment, it's truly
sterile. Then I guess there's two questions.
Should we be bringing along an environmental
microbiome to live in? But if we bring it
from the earth and we dump it on Mars -- which
has less gravity, different radiation environment
-- is it going to go through its own epigenetic
change and not be the thing we want to be
surrounded by? I mean, I know it's very hard
to predict.
Well there's some evidence, we know bacteria
in space become more virulent and have more
resistance to antibiotics. That's been published
by multiple groups. There's even an analogue
even in hospitals, if you look at where the
most antimicrobial resistance markers of the
antibiotic resistance, it's actually present
more on the surfaces than it is of the patients,
from a paper just published two weeks ago,
writ large. The idea being that they're under
such strong selection pressure you might be
enriching for the organisms that might be
the most resistant effectively on these surfaces.
And so it's been one study but it had fifteen
hundred samples, so it's really an intriguing
thought. So to your point, when we send people
anywhere you're sending an ecosystem not just
a person, as well as what their environment
-- and they'll be under a lot more intense
and faster selection pressure as soon as they
get to Mars.
So I think we will have to have you know rapid
diagnostics. You can't send a sample back
to Earth to see what the bacteria is, you'll
have to sequence it there on Mars. And one
of the things we worked on with a team at
NASA was just to do the first DNA sequencing
in space. And so it's now possible to actually
do diagnostics of what it is, so if you had
to pick from one of ten antibiotics, you might
be able to know right away which one to pick
instead of guessing.
Chris, I heard that NASA has a very, very
stringent sterilization process for all the
equipment that actually is one of the difficulties
for designing equipment. And that also, many
years ago a group of individuals or nations
got together to designate certain planets
or certain -- I guess they banned the contamination
of planets. And I think that's being reassessed.
What's the status on that?
The Planetary Protection -- basically it's
an organization within NASA as well as an
agreement between ESA and Jackson, and NASA
is to, as the name sounds you want to protect
other planets from us, vermin, and filth,
us that will go out and distribute our filth.
But really they are obviously for discovery
purposes, they're relatively pristine environments
and you don't want to have discovered alien
life just to have discovered what you brought
with. I actually just had a long email exchange
yesterday with a guy who sequenced the organism
that was cultured from the space station and
he thinks it's alien because it evolved to
be different enough from what's on Earth and
we're debating about whether that's true.
It's a string of bacillus and they're funky
to begin with.
But you know the idea is that we -- I think
it's interesting for two reasons. One is that
it's probably already failed. If you sequenced
the DNA in clean rooms (these are the samples
we're getting in two weeks from now), there's
DNA everywhere. It's really it's literally
impossible to get rid of the most abundant
biomolecule on this planet. You know the DNA
is everywhere if you look at what where it's
coming from, and maybe cellulose is the most
abundant, but in terms of an information-content
molecule, it's everywhere. It's in the air,
it's in the atmosphere, it's deep underground,
it's in hydrothermal vents -- you know there
are bacteria that have had billions of years
of a head start. So they're everywhere. And
we've seen if you take the blank samples from
the cleanroom, they're not actually always
clean. So on the one hand we think maybe we've
already failed or succeeded, depending on
your perspective.
But the other thing is I think eventually,
if you think long, long term, this idea of
planetary protection is fallacious from its
foundation. If you think long enough ahead,
let's say three or four billion years, eventually
the sun will engulf the near planets. And
so let's say we've done a perfect job and
we have wonderful world peace on Earth and
it's Kumbaya every night and there's no famine,
there's no disease, there's no war -- it's
wonderful. But if we're all still here on
Earth, we will all die if we're still here
in three billion years, so again it's a ways
off, but it doesn't matter if you've protected
all the planets, shey will all be engulfed
by the sun. So if you really want to think
about long term preservation of our species
as well as all those of which we're responsible
for, at some point you'll have to go to another
planet and therefore you know lay down the
microbes that were never from there. So the
talk then, to state we live here on this planet
-- we'll have to eventually go to others or
if we don't, it will all go away except for
what we broadcast into space. So I think it's
a nice idea that eventually will have to fail.
That's how I would describe it.
So far, most of what we've talked about is
sort of haphazard in the evolutionary sense
of haphazard. That is, these things will go
out there, they'll survive or they won't survive,
they'll undergo natural selection, maybe some
sort of epigenetic modification if they're
lucky to get through a couple of generations.
But what about the possibility of actually
designing things to go out there, which we
can do now even to our cells with techniques
like CRISPR-Cas9, gene drive. Maybe you could
explain a little bit of that for us and whether
or not this is the kind of thing we should
be thinking about and doing.
I definitely think this is something we should
think about, not just for space applications,
but on the planet. So people have been modifying
genomes for a long, long time. We have quite
a wide variety of ways of doing it but there
are a couple of things that made it not reasonable
to think about modifying in any practical
way and one is the targeting and the others
the efficiency. Those are the two things that
held-
By "targeting", you mean…?
Targeting, you want to modify this part of
a chromosome, you want to just modify that
and you want to do it efficiently. And until
recently, we did not have the machinery, the
enzymatic machinery to do that. And then just
a few years ago, 2013, through this technique,
this mechanism called CRISPR, we now have
the efficiency and much, much better targeting,
as well as two other very good technologies
for modifying genomes: zinc fingers and TALENs.
So this triumvirate of machineries really
give us tremendous potential to modify genomes.
And I think probably many of you have been
involved or read articles, or been involved
in conversations having to do with just how
much do we want to apply this? I would say
it's really almost as if our species has moved
into a new era, we passed a milestone where
we can now intellectually understand ourselves
before even an individual is born, and have
a better understanding -- not perfect understanding.
And now we have the capacity to design. So…
And the responsibility that comes with it,
presumably.
And the responsibility, right. And it brings
up the issue of judgment. We now can think
about genomes and judge them based on all
different kinds of measuring sticks. And this
is what I think the world is thinking very
hard about. We need to involve all different
communities in this.
I'd like to talk about the twins experiment
now, in space -- so back into space a little
bit -- which you were very involved in so
maybe you could tell us a little bit about
Mark and…
Scott Kelly.
Mark and Scott Kelly.
For those not familiar with the study, it
was a plan to -- it was a really unique opportunity
because we had twin brothers, both of whom
are actually astronauts. So could you imagine
being -- I don't know if any in the room are
parents -- but can you imagine being a parent
and being like, "Oh both my sons are astronauts."
People would be at a party and be like, "Yeah
whatever, it's not really true." Like, "No
really, both my sons, my twins sons are both
astronauts."
So there must be a gene for it. I mean clearly
there's an astronaut gene.
We've confirmed that they're twins with the
genome sequence and I can say that for sure
if we had been if we confirmed
They the plan was it was actually launched
at a press conference because Scott Kelly
was going up for the longest American mission
in space which is a full year. And when they
were planning the mission, you can see it
up there, that there as they were planning
out the mission, they said you know, she was
one of the reporters who said well “you
know when on Earth are you guys doing anything
with the twin?” And they said well we don't
know everything in the plan but as soon as
the press conference, so here's a big high
five that the press to ask good questions,
is they said we should do something soon.
Actually the twins themselves really proposed
it to NASA and said we should do something.
So they had an announcement to have people
submit applications and I had actually sent
an application to do astronaut genomes back
and 2010 when I had just started my laboratory.
Actually wrote this really interesting grant,
I said “I don't want any money from you
I just want DNA” and they hadn't yet been
banking DNA from astronauts. Because normally
when you start a lab they give you some funds
to get started, so it was a peculiar grant
but they said “well we don't actually have
anything banked yet”. But then eventually
when I knew they made the announcement, said
so great I’ve got most of it written and
submitted and was one of the labs selected
for. They said okay we have identical twins
and we are going to monitor them everything
we possibly can because the big question was
well “what changes in the body when you're
in space” and I said so “well, no one's
ever looked so we don't know so we should
look at everything we possibly can to understand
the physiological changes to the body.”
So we're looking at the DNA with changes of
genetically, epigenetically that we talked
about, the modifications of DNA. What happens
to your RNA molecules or your transcriptome
as well as the modifications to RNA which
we talked about. Protein changes, metabolites,
how DNA is wrapped in package in all your
cells. Microbes in the stomach and the skin
in the mouth and also in the environment,
but also looking are what are called metabolomics,
are small molecules in your blood. Cognition
how fast actually they can do tasks. We are
also looking at vasculature and doing full
body MRIs and doing all these test. We had
over nineteen time points.
The amazing thing about the study was not
only ,it felt like a Michael Crichton novel,
if you know Michael Crichton's books, where
they get a peculiar mix of scientists like
you a mathematician, and you need a geneticist
I mean a physicist to go to Jurassic park.
It was like a weird mixture of people and
there are too. We have a telomere biologist,
some geneticists some proteomics experts a
guy who spends all day designing computer
games for cognition testing, a cardiologist,
its really it's a team effort and you know
which is one of the team. But it's also forces
to think about systems biology, so you want
to measure all of these changes and then integrate
them, there actually is not really an infrastructure
that exists either for medical records at
hospitals or for astronaut-monitoring to integrate
all that information. So it's been a computational,
exciting challenge, you talked about challenge
before. It's great because it's the most challenging
integration problem that we have.
But then also some of the biology has been
really interesting. We've actually seen already
that you're telomeres get longer in space,
the stress response genes really activate,
the microbiome inside your gut changes, but
that wasn't too surprising, they’re are
also eating different food. And we can also
see you know some of the responses to the
hypoxia you know the changes and whether it
changes in oxygen and
Was the earthbound brother or the same diet
and all the rest of that.
We tried to get Mark to have the same diet
and he politely refused or actually not politely,
he definitively refused and said “you can
go…”, and you can imagine the rest of
that sentence. But we did get them both to
keep food logs and his log though was more
you know…so Scott's up in space is highly
regulated food. It's rehy, rehydrated and
then heated. There's a little bit of exchange
with the Russian side so they do exchange
some food and other odd things we keep track
of, so the Russian water supply is different
from the American and European. The Russians
put a little bit of copper into their water
supply whereas the Americans don't. But they
both try and get rid of microbial contaminants,
o we have to track that as well. And but but
Mark's food log was more you know burritos
and Margaritas and it was very, very, very
terrestrial
So they don’t send any booze up in space
at all?
You can get a care package.
Now, I’m definitely out
So. So are there any benefits to being in
space. Good come of it for your genome your
body or anything.
This is an ongoing debate amongst all the
twins investigators because we keep getting
this question because all we keep talking
about is you know permanent changes to your
microbiome, epigenetic changes, the only potentially
you know benefit might be is the telomere
lengthening. And actually they come back in
pretty good shape it's because they have to
exercise every single morning for at least
thirty to forty five minutes just to maintain
their bone density And so it really is…
Did you get the earthbound brother to do that?
No again he did the Margarita.
There’s not of lot of controls in this thing.
So we do often joke, incorrectly, that this
is the worst powered study in human history
has an n two instead of an n of one because
of twins. And so we know this study was was
never designed and never could be the definitive
measure of what happens of the body in space..you
know writ large.
but it is the first time NASA has gotten into
genomics. It's the first time they really
want to think about precision medicine for
astronauts which they have a nice poster now
that models all this. And they want to begin
to look at the question if we have a genome
could we think about who is at higher risk
for hypoxia related genes or those people
might respond better or worse to different
pharmacological treatments in space. So they,
they are doing very much what our healthcare
system is in having a genome guided view of
medicine, your genome and your microbes.
So would this ever reflect back on who could
be an astronaut and who couldn't.
This is an ongoing point of contention within
NASA. So they, the IRB that we got for the
twins study itself took
Institutional review board documents that
you need for a human experiments
Before you do any experiments on humans, you
need to have a board to go through and make
sure you're not doing evil things to them
as you can imagine. And there's unfortunate
history in genetics and eugenics where really
bad things were done without institutional
review boards to make sure you're informing
the patients of the risks, and making sure
that you know all the experiments are medically
necessary and they have good controls.
So, we this was the first time it's been done
for NASA and they we want to use this for
subsequent astronauts. But they it's they
don't -- The flight surgeons and the astronauts
have kind of a love hate relationship more
kind of hate hate is that they. The flight
surgeons are always looking for something
to potentially, you know maybe that's a high
risk and that if they flag something has to
be a risk that they'll keep someone from going
on the mission. And all the astronauts have
trained for years, some cases decades, and
it's their life's dream to go to space and
so they will do things that you would imagine
humans would do is, the decimeter which tells
you how much radiation you've had they'll
hide it in the space station so they can go
back up for different missions but keep it
in a protected part of the space station or
they will do what
Really?
They want to go back up, it's their dream
right.
Is it addictive? Is there a space addiction?
We can look in the genes.
So there's a big debate in NASA of how much
can we really reliably tell someone about
whether they should or should not go to space
just based on their genome. And most of the
consensus is we're not there yet that we could
say it but it's a question of I think when
not if. And it's not it's, like, a little
bit like this movie Gattaca. I would expect
most people in this room probably seen it.
Hopefully not the bad version of that, hoping
it would be all the information that you could
do to protect yourself, and for example from
your genome you can tell what drugs you should
or should not take that you would respond
well to or not or your microbial genome. So
hopefully would use the good of genomes to
reinforce good genetic circuits as well as
even protect them as they hope.
I think this situation is made more, put in
starker relief because the trips that people
are anticipating now are longer. And so you're
going to be taking a ten year journey, then
you can, actually for some cancers calculate
a predisposition or chance that you are going
to develop a cancer in a very long period
of time and you'll be too far away to come
back for treatment. And I think that's where
the discussion of genetic, personal genetics
has become a little more interesting.
And there, you have to, you have to take it
into consideration it would be foolish not
to. So you know it's a big if, if all the
evidence is solid and grounded and replicated
and really informative then it should be used
but it's getting all the scientists and the
flight surgeons at the point where they all
feel comfortable making that decision. But
I think when you think of missions to Mars
or longer missions, you know that you can't
get back fast
I thought we would…oh go on
Oh well I you know this is very interesting
and I was thinking about Mars specifically,
because you know really the only way to learn
the peculiarities of the Martian environment
and its impact on humans is going to be to
send that first batch of, you know, ideally
many practical twins to do that experiment.
Because it will be it will be a very different
experience in low earth orbit. The radiation
environment on route for let's say six months
will be different and the stresses of that
will be different, and then the experience
on the surface, which no human has yet set
foot on Mars so we don't have the slightest
idea. It's a it's a different chemical environment
that you're going to have a hard time keeping
out of your, you know and out of your potato
chips if you stray outside of the habitat.
I
Like in The Martian?
In The Martian. So that's interesting. I mean
it almost sounds like, you would have to have
a biological expedition would be one of the
first things to do.
I have a question for you, do you think that
it would be a good intermediate step to not,
to focus of course to trying it on the plan
and certain live on a separate planet, but
to actually create a space station that will
where we would be able to control the environment
better rather than focus entirely on trying
to get on a planet or alter the planet, alter
ourselves to live on that planet. Your knowledge
of the of universe, what do you think it is.
Well it's an interesting question. I mean
I suspect from a practical point of view,
from a rocket science point of view it may
be equally challenging to construct, let's
say a more elaborate space station that say
mimics Martian gravity for example because
that's something you would want to do for
it to be worthwhile. Also if it's in low Earth
orbit you will not be exposed to the same
radiation environment. So you're really talking
about, I think, it sounds like a reasonable
idea to me but it would be a structure space
station that would have to be, maybe it would
be orbiting the moon or something like that
to get a little bit closer to what you need
for that experiment.
Actually, I was thinking more of that rather
than trying to find a planet where we could
thrive and make it like our environment just
to perhaps forego that, and so we find a planet
that is perfect for us and instead work on
building a station that is just like Earth.
I mean unfortunately you know if there are
planets perfect for us there are a long way
away around other stars. So then we're into
the whole realm of interstellar exploration.
And you know, well this is something that
circles back to my first comments about you
know we have this picture, Hollywood is partly
to blame and also of wishful thinking over
the years, of you know going to Mars. Mars
is the other habitable planet and of course
it's an appalling place. You know there's
almost no atmosphere, it has less gravity
it's got nasty surface chemistry, has less
shielding against ultraviolet radiation and
cosmic radiation..
You know and it makes me think back to it.
I mean there's this sort of little anecdote
about how we get so fixated on certain ideas
going back to the very first robotic spacecraft
to go past Mars, I think the late nineteen
sixties like Mariner four, I think was the
first fly, and then there was Mariner seven
or nine was an orbiter - the first U.S. orbiter
to get to Mars. You can actually go and look
at the original scientific literature and
people like Carl Sagan, who was active at
that point, was literally writing papers speculating
that well when we get to Mars and start taking
the high resolution images we may see this
pattern of vegetation. If there’s this pattern
of vegetation that might be certain types
of herbivores and so on.
And of course will two things happened, first
they get to Mars and Mars is encased in one
of its global dust storms. And so all that
could be seen, the first close up high res
orbital images of Mars were the peaks of Olympus
Mons and a couple of the other Tharsis volcanoes
and the rest of the planet was covered in
dust so they actually had to wait a couple
of months. I mean it must've been really I
mean, it's kind of a science fictiony thing,
your waiting for the clouds to clear, all
the dust storms to clear to reveal…more
dust. And a terrible planet /
Where’d they think all that dust came from.
Well yeah you know, I mean I'm sure people
I'm sure people speculated.
So it's just by way of saying that yeah, so
in our solar system so coming back to what
you said. I agree. I mean it's the engineering
challenges are different, some advantages
of building a a raw space habitat for yourself
as you don't have to lift it in and out of
a gravity field all the time. Getting stuff
down onto Mars is a complete nightmare because
you don't have much of an atmosphere to break
yourself actually. And this is why the last
big rover couldn't use the airbags to bounce
on the surface and do the final slowdown,
it had to use some kind of rocket crane system
because there isn't enough atmosphere, there’s
enough gravity to get you to the surface hard,
but there isn't enough atmosphere to use as
a natural break. But you know what is interesting
to me the idea of a fully contained space
station is, do we know how to do that for
the long term. I mean the ISS gets resupplied
you know you can you can flush out things
every so often I assume.
Sometimes when you see a shooting star at
night it's not if a shooting the star.
I’m not going to ask what it is, but I can
guess. Can you tell if it's Russian or American?
Different emission spectra, you can see the
color. It’s the vodka.
And I think it's a fascinating question.
So that took the romance out of it.
And I think it's, I think it's a very very
interesting question but it is an immense
challenge and I you know if you actually add
up the total mass that humans have elevated
from the surface of the earth and put it into
space it's not very much. I mean it's, I did
this calculation at some point and I think
it's some tiny fraction of the mass of an
oil tanker has actually been lifted into space
even though there are thousands of pieces
of satellite junk floating around. It's really
expensive
And not that many people have actually, you
know, about four hundred sixty seven, actually
four hundred seventy two people have left
the earth and then come back. But there's
not that many people you know have ever experienced
it. But, but it's a good question, maybe a
self-contained environment or waiting until
we find the right place. But even if it is
the right place to send people there, they
a lot of them would probably not make it.
And I think our intuitions about this where
everyone wants to go there and have it be
,you know Kumbaya and be fine. But think about
the people who first came to Plymouth Rock
in the first winter more than ninety percent
of them died that winter. But more came the
next year and so I think the entrepreneurial
and pioneering kind of spirit it may require,
or historically has required a lot of sacrifice.
And you know there's a contrast when they
came to Plymouth Roc there was an atmosphere
here there was water. It was easier. But they're
they're they're very I mean I think NASA has
you know a lot of really great homages to
the astronauts they've lost over the years
and but they all recognize it's a really high
risk job. And I think it will be true whenever
and however we send people
Another possibility and this is something
I think I've even written briefly about. You
know there are places on Earth you could begin
to test some of the, actually and it's not
just the desert somewhere, but you know set
up your colony on Everest. You know at the
top of Everest right where people usually
die just, right, because there isn't enough
oxygen to sustain you for any great length
of time, there's a lot more UV radiation.
You know there is no natural resource you
can't grow tomatoes. Right. So there's some
interesting, perhaps interesting experiments
that could be done here on Earth not just
building a pretend Mars habitat in, you know
Iceland or something, which is interesting
from for testing the psychological aspects
of isolation and so all we could do a little
bit better here on Earth
I was talking with a physician at NASA about
the immediate problems, bone loss, muscle
loss, kidney stones, visual problems blood
pressure problems. And but for many of the
Sounds like me and I’m not even an astronaut
yet, I’m doing that all on my own.
What these physician said, and so this might
be more encouraging for you…
I’m waiting.
They said these problems are very complicated
for the first few days of the first few weeks.
But then interestingly, the human body acclimates.
And they say even bone loss and muscle loss
is appropriate for space where things weigh
less. And where the fact, they say you get
calluses on the top of your feet because you're
using the top of your feet to hold you in
place, you lose the calluses on the bottom.
And they say after a while the human body
acclimates for long term. And the problem
is when they come back to Earth. So these
habitats that we build and these things that
we think are terrible for our body in the
long run, he was saying, actually the body
may be adjusting just the way it needs to
be just for the long term.
Even Scott when he came back to Earth, one
of the hardest things that had happened in
his first day back was that his the weight
of clothes made his skin hurt. And so he had
because he hadn't felt the weight of his clothes.
So he had notoriously spend some of the time
just wandering around the house native and
just to just think it was too painful to work
clothes.
How does his brother feel about that?
So they weren’t or Skyping or Facetiming
that much
They were fine up in space. Yeah.
So the trick is to send people out there and
not let them come back in other words. Just
a one way ticket
OK. With that let's let's take some questions.
This is salon so we'd love to hear from you
guys as well. That's OK good. Sure. We have
some questions? Yes, give him a try. He was
before he blasts off.
So, hi I’m Mishan. And my question is, you
talk in the beginning a lot about like biology
and how human genes could make humans adapt.
But like if someone want to Mars right, and
they were like having a baby with a baby would
develop differently in the fetus it would
have maybe weaker bones and less muscle mass
and stuff like that. Do you thin they would
they be able to return back to Earth, with
the weaker bone mass and the weaker muscle
mass and the like never being experienced
to the high gravity and high atmospheric pressure
of Earth?
Great question, the answer is: it would definitely
hurt when they came back here, I think it
wouldn't necessarily be impossible unless
it was thousands and thousands of years it
could eventually become literally a different
species of quite possibly. If \ they were
if they were to come here would be too painful
or they would then need spacesuits to come
to Earth and they would be just have been
our cousins. So you could very well imagine
that with enough time they will become a different
species. So I think that it's actually inevitable.
I mean even if just people go, people living
in the South versus the Northeast have different
accents and it didn't take that long really.
So the good start with language to start with
culture will start with intonations and very
quickly it manifests in the biology and the
selection pressure will be so fast and so
strong I think it'll be, it be an extraordinary
evolutionary experiment on our on our own
species but I think there will be changes.
Well that sort of raises a certain irony.
These ideas for example, Elon Musk talking
about colonizing Mars is the backup plan except
they won't be human after a while. So it's
not quite the backup plan you had in mind
And he wants to get there, NASA wants to be
there by 2030 or 2035 and he wants to beat
them. So there's a bit of a battle between
them. But it should be soon actually, you
would be about the right age to actually be
one of the first for people to go to Mars.
You can sign up in the other room
One way rocket, one way rocket.
Do we have another?
It's so hard to visualize the future it's
so far away. And there are tons of problems
that come up immediately and I was you know
what I'm kind of concerned that there's a
lack of discussion about it because obviously
everybody has different experiences and views
on ethics and stuff. And I was wondering what
kind of people you think should be in charge
of dictating the ethics of genetics and balancing
future thinking with present day problems.
That is such a timely perfect question. I
think that geneticists realize we have, as
I mentioned before, moved into a new era.
We have the capacity to really change the
way genetics enters our lives and how it affects
our lives. I think we all recognize, also,
that we are in service to the world. It's
not it's less and less what we think is fun
to do.
When I was a student it was hard to figure
out how things worked. You know how did this
happen? How did how did this evolve? Very
much now it's turned into we know enough of
how this works that we have the capacity to
invent something. We know enough about the
basis of this disease and the location of
this disease that that we can think about
changing it. And that so we're no longer in
solidly in the discovery mode we're in the
mode of altering our environment. You are
our environment, we're all part of the environment.
So I think you will find greater, greater
agreement among scientists that this is a
world problem and it's going to have to be
solved by world discussion. Are there certain
people that will be chosen? I certainly hope
not. I think and the more noise people make
the more opinions you voice the less chance
it's going to be made by a small group of
people. I don't think we want to make it with
a small group of people. It rests really on
how much involvement all of you take onto
your onto yourselves
I echo definitely, is so far. I think it should
be a community effort, I mean the scientists
talking with everyone in the community, you
know religious scholars to people working
in every different discipline. And one interesting
thing is, I think it should not be just left
up to the scientists themselves. Actually
at the meeting we were recently at the genome
project right meaning there was a survey during
a meeting of one of the questions was “Do
you think scientists are doing enough to mitigate
potential risks and think about the ethics
of the problem of engineering genomes?”
And seventy percent of the people at the meeting
said well yeah I think so. I said well that
right there I tweeted that and that was the
reason why we shouldn't just depend on the
scientists because it's too easy to fall in
love with the data and to see the awesome
power and potential of the biology and the
tweaking of it to improve life and eradicate
disease. You can easily get caught up and
think oh this is great and it's we're thinking
about and we have panels, but you know I think
it's not going to be enough, and most people
at the meeting was optimistic very much welcome
feedback, comments they want to they want
everyone to be involved and if they don't
then they're working with Dr. Evil.
I would say, I welcome the idea and in many
ways that that will once again begin listening
to philosophers and historians and science
and not just the technicians as it were. So
I think that's actually…. I see this optimistically
I would say if we get that back in the mix.
Questions, more questions?
If we as a species are going to continue we
are going to be thinking about millions even
billions of years into the future, so there
will become a point where even Mars is not
a habitable place for us. So expanding on
to outer reaches of the solar system and beyond
and that the farther we get apart, species
of humans will become isolated and possibly
speciate.
Are you thinking about the heat the heat death
of the universe it keeps expanding? If you
keep going eventually that's where you end
up for sure.
But more of the idea in that we will at some
point hopefully be expanding outside of our
solar system, beyond the influences of the
dangers of radiation from our own sun. And
my question was what influences are humans
going to have in deep space on our physiology
and living beyond the influence of our own
sun?
The radiation environment of our sun is certainly
an issue but there's plenty of so called cosmic
radiation that comes from other sources throughout
our galaxy, comes from other stars, it comes
from you know black holes consuming matter
that comes of neutron stars. It comes from
particles accelerated and galactic magnetic
field. We have a bit of an idea of what that
environment is like. It's pretty similar to
sort of deep interplanetary environment in
our own solar system. So it's it's kind of
nasty.
It's not any safer?
It's probably not any safer. And yeah. And
also just to add to that I mean let's just
think about it with the element of realism.
To get to another star in a reasonable amount
of time, now we may have to engineer humans
to live longer to do this efficiently. But
you will have to move fast moving fast through
interstellar space brings all sorts of hazards
that are quite mechanical, I mean, you know
you may spend most of your time patching up
your colony ship because a microscopic piece
of interstellar dust has zipped through and,
you know, went through Stu's cocktail. But
I think it's I mean the radiation environment
I think is is pretty similar to deep into
planetary space.
So I know geneticists are trying to identify
the genes involved in DNA repair, but we also
are looking for ways in which the genome,
which plays a big part in our life, can withstand
onslaught. My lab in particular is interested
in some very mysterious sequences in all of
us, people don't know what they do. They're
the least evolving sequences known, by definition.
They've been in all of us for three to five
hundred million years without change, essentially
without change and their big surprise for
genomicists.
A do not disturb sign...
Do not disturb. But recently some of our work
has shown, that I suggested, that they are
like some we call them genomic canaries. They're
scattered all over your genome. And what we
think they do, they’re a model, and when
they detect a damaging break in the chromosome
they get rid of the cell that has that break.
So I think it's possible as we explore our
genome more and more we're going to find the,
the tools to be able to fashion ourselves
to withstand radiation damage.
Perhaps, we're also studying in the lab desiccation.
There are cells that you can desiccate down
to nothing you can modify human cells and
some insect cells on their own you can modify
it can dry them. It's kind of fun working
this field when someone sends you cells normally
they have to pack it in dry ice they send
it to you pick it up at FedEx put in the freezer.
These cells you send in an envelope you just
pop it in the envelope and send it through
the mail. You keep the cells in your drawer
because they're dry. Nothing's going to happen
to you add water and they grow. So, I think
we're trying to fashion tools that may be
useful for long term travel in space. Other
people are trying to come up with ways in
which lifespan can be extended tremendously,
will these be new species?
Potentially.
Potentially. But I think our mind is so creative
I think so far as you said the extremes that
we see within our own solar system, if we
can conquer those, it is possible we can conquer
others.
There was a famous mathematical evolutionary
biologist named J.B.S Haldane, English who
once famously said not only is the universe
stranger than we imagine a stranger than we
can imagine. And that's often been seen to
be some sort of a limit of our cognitive abilities,
can we really. But the interesting thing is
you said that I think in 1927 or 29 and since
then we've actually imagined some pretty strange
crap. That you never would have imagined we
could have imagined so. So that prediction
has not actually come true. And I find that
a very positive
I also think that people thought, that when
you're on those long missions people thought
you would just be at the whim of the universe
and have to be subjugated this damage. But
with CRISPR and genome-repair systems you
could much like your continually repairing
or shipping constantly repairing your DNA
on the way. And you would actually, I think
we'd have to do that actually. And then if
it's a long enough mission you'd have to have
multiple generations that live and die on
the same vessel before they get to the planet
which sounds awful. but if you have all of
Netflix for the whole mission, I don’t know.
And ot a few things you would have to deal
with here. We have time for another a couple
of questions.
What is your confidence that Mars will be
colonized in your lifetimes or in this boy's
lifetime?
By colonize, dyou mean people having children
and spending their whole lifetime there? Well
I'm pretty old.
I think it probably won't be in my lifetime,
I will be, I'll be really happy just if we
get there. And if we have my life's work is
in any way contributed to help that make possible
I think in his lifetime it's possible that
would be the very first real colonist is there.
But, but it's a rough place as if we heard.
It's awfully difficult to predict. You know
you've got to. Well yeah. Yeah. But you've
got to put in this case you've got to predict
the nature of human will and you know the
reality of chances of those those first colonists
that never coming back. I mean that's certainly
the Elon Musk plan and it makes a great deal
of sense because it's awfully difficult to
bring people back again. But I you know I
think it's conceivable. Let's say Tesla does
really well in the next year and. That within
the next ten to twenty years will be an effort
at least there will be some sort of attempt
at an outpost. I don't know if it would be
considered a colony.
We're out of time. Let me thank the panel
Chris, Caleb, Ting for a great conversation.